Climate change is the most urgent threat facing
human civilization today.
For the people of Bangladesh, rising seas,
flooding, salinity intrusion, cyclones, and
extreme heat waves have already caused families
to lose their livelihoods, homes and communities.
Globally, Bangladesh is just the start.
These changes are accelerating. Within the next few decades,
climate change will force many millions to
migrate.
MIT and BRAC will transform climate adaptation by creating CREWSNET, the Climate Resilience
Early Warning System Network.
CREWSNET puts cutting edge climate forecasting technology directly into the hands of individuals
to show how future climate and extreme weather
patterns will impact their lives.
This technology, combined with access to innovative
power, water, agriculture, and financing services...will
empower families, communities, and governments
to make and implement informed, proactive
decisions about how to adapt to this changing
world.
This widely accessible, integrated tool will
enable civil society organizations to better
support these choices, and strengthen efforts
to create climate resilient communities throughout
Bangladesh.
CREWSNET will serve as a model for people
everywhere facing similar threats to their
livelihood and survival.
Together, we can create a better future...
for Bangladesh and the world.